practice drills over the baltic sea by
british french and danish pilots
western powers are honing their response
to russia's military buildup near
ukraine with a display of combat
readiness the danes have also sent
fighter jets and a frigate to join nato
efforts in the baltic
do too much and the alliance risks being
drawn into a conflict in a country they
have no treaty obligation to protect
do too little and a potential russian
invasion risks destabilizing not just
ukraine but the entire region if the
worst happens and the destructive
firepower of the russian army were to
engulf ukraine's towns and cities i
shudder to contemplate the tragedy that
would ensue and the bloodshed comparable
to the first war in chechnya or bosnia
four thousand nato troops are on standby
in the baltic states estonia latvia and
lithuania once part of the soviet union
they're now ardent nato members and
thousands more reinforcements are ready
to deploy there
in ukraine itself small contingents of
american and british troops have been
training local forces a flow of military
aids been arriving too
this a shipment of british anti-tank
weapons
and these are boxes of american
ammunition to help ukraine defend itself
since 2014 the u.s alone has spent two
and a half billion dollars arming the
ukrainian military with defense systems
and electric warfare units all at no
cost
and the eu says it's mobilizing all
resources to fend off cyber attacks the
commission proposes a new emergency
macro financial assistance package
agreeing also this week on a 1.7 billion
dollar financial aid package to help
ukraine and importantly ukrainians
weather any drawn out conflict
all this of course is what we know about
covert and overt operations are
happening simultaneously with the uk
last week claiming the russians were
planning to install this man as a puppet
president following a successful
takeover of the country russia dismissed
the claims true or false nato wants
russia to know its joint intelligence
efforts are trained on moscow
western agencies that are analyzing this
know for instance that right now the
russian forces aren't really ready to
conduct any kind of attack against
ukraine but they know that in two weeks
they will be
so it's about
as in all forms of deterrence or
compellence it's about signaling intent
but it may be the threat of never seen
before sanctions against russia by the
eu us and others to prove the most
effective deterrent in the west's
arsenal
russia's 2014 annexation of ukraine's
crimean peninsula caught allied western
forces off guard with european security
once again at stake the nato alliance
wants its presence firmly felt
neave barker al jazeera london